hello
i'm ivan vas gonzalos i'm an assistant
professor of applied geoscience at
reuters university in the netherlands
welcome to the third and final part of
solving large-scale inverse problems in
python
with pylops in this part
we're going to look at the jupiter
notebook called
radon in this jupyter notebook that you
now see here
we're going to follow a few steps and in
these steps
we're going to fulfill the following
objectives
now what you've seen from pilot so far
is what pileups is
how to set it up and you've now seen
relatively straightforward examples on
how to use
the pilot's functionality to address
problems
in image processing in this part
what we will address is how to do
firstly
uh how to take third-party software
and make it into a pilot operator
secondly we're going to look how to
build more complex
pileups operators for specific problems
more importantly
we're going to look at how to use these
made pileups operators to solve
optimization problems now we're going to
do that in the context of a specific
inverse problem
and this is the problem of the inverse
radon transform
the inverse radon transform is the
problem that appears
in computerized tomography or ct imaging
or
in mri imaging therefore it's one of the
most
well-known and studied imaging
problems out there bear in mind that the
things that we're going to show here
are not state of the art in ct or mri
imaging
the purpose of this tutorial is to get
you familiarized as to how to build an
operator from
either scratch or using third-party
software
into a full inverse problem using
pileups optimization tools
we picked this example because it is a
popular example
but bear in mind that there are
more sophisticated tools for this
problem
if that's what you want to solve okay so
let's get started
with our problem to understand the
problem
of image reconstruction with the inverse
radon transform
let's look at this cartoon here okay so
this cartoon
demonstrates what is called the fourier
slice theorem
the fourier slice theorem relates an
image which is what you see here as
i to the 2d fourier spectrum
of that image k through what are called
parallel projections now parallel
projections here
in this cartoon are demonstrated here by
the blue arrows that show what would
have been a
shadow of the x-ray excitation
as recorded along the line so on this
side of the image you would have
accessory sources
and here you would record the x-ray
transmission on the other side
because some of the x-ray would have
been scattered by in this case the body
or some sort of target you would see a
loss in power in x-ray
and this is the projection as we call it
here
now if you take a projection over a line
oriented speed
take its fourier transform here
indicated in two by showing
diagrammatically its fourier components
and place them along
a specific wave number that corresponds
to the k direction
you can build by taking successive
progressions at directions p
the fourier spectrum of this 2d image
and then by taking the inverse fourier
transform
of the k spectrum you can recover the
image
from the projections this is called the
2d
fourier slice theorem
the main idea here is that we can relate
an image to its projections so now we're
going to talk about how to build
an image by using projection operators
to begin with uh we're going to start
by looking at a specific
uh setup here for our projections
okay so uh this is a little recipe that
you can follow to build projections
what i want you to pay attention here is
that we have some options right
if we have a set of projections p so you
can see here in this equation
as a function of an image and a
projection operator p
we could simply invert that projection
operator
if we have the fourier transform and
related to sampling
then we can look at the fourier
dual of that projection that's now in
space k
and we could have the fourier transform
applied to the image
and then sampled by a restriction
operator r
before we do any of this in pylops or
starting point
would be to say well is there a package
out there that has something that we can
use
well it turns out that scikit image has
a raiden operator
so to start we're going to look at the
forward radon transform
that comes from scikit image and we're
going to look at an image reconstruction
straight out of scikit image
using the so called filtered back
projection
so let's start adding remember
when you want to run this code if you're
running an enco app
you'll have to run this first line here
so you can install both pilots and
scooby
in this case we're in a local
environment so i'll just run the code
here we're importing our libraries which
include pylops scooby psychic image
as or baseline the very first thing
we'll do
is we'll import what's called the shep
logan image okay so i'll do this here
and here you can see a picture of the
image this is a
2d image that's often used as a common
benchmark
for ct mri image reconstruction problems
so
for that purpose we're using it here for
the same thing
this is the image that we start from
this is the image that we want to
reconstruct okay
so let's start now with a scikit image
version of radon you can see what's
happening here in the codes
first thing that we do is we choose a
set of angles to which
we get projections that's between 0 and
180 degrees
at every 3 degrees we call
the radon transform directly from scikit
image
and that will produce a projection set
to us
so if we evaluate this bit of code
here now you can see on the left hand
side the input image the shep logan
phantom
and its projections as generated by
scikit radon
now this picture shows you the intensity
of the projection this is what you see
in the gray color
as a function of space
along some line at projection p so these
are pixels here
think of them as just coordinates along
the line
that is slanted at a p and the piece
length is given by an
angle that's the projection angle that
you see in the horizontal axis
okay so uh we know now that we have
the uh radon transform and that the
random transform
outputs discrete projection values at
locations
along a line and for a specific angle
can we make an image back from it well
scikit image
already has for us a functionality
called iradon
and iradon can produce what is called
the filtered back projection
okay this is not an inverse this is a
back projection
much like an adjoint would produce a
back projection
so let's just run it and see what we get
here we called the inverse read on with
the option
of the projection and we get a picture
back
and this is the picture this is a
reconstruction of our image
coming from the psychic image iradon
functionality
on the left hand side you see the
reconstruction on the right hand side
you see the reconstruction error
for this picture and all other pictures
here where we show a reconstruction
error notice
that we're not showing the magnitudes of
the reconstruction error
we leave it to you to find out how large
these reconstruction errors are
but you can use the pictures as they're
shown to appreciate the patterns
in the reconstruction memory so
now that we have what appears to be a
forward operator which produced
our projections and an inverse which uh
or
a pseudo inverse a back projection here
in the shape of the filter back
projection
can we build this into a pylops operator
okay and the answer is yes to do this
we're going to use a functionality of
pallops
called the function operator this is
what you see
highlighted right here the function
operator
allows you to take python functions and
pass them
as the forward and adjoint method to a
function operator construct in pylops
which returns a pilot's operator class
that operates
as the pilot operators that you've seen
in the last two parts
here the way we do this is to use the
lambda functionality of python
to call both the radon and iran method
functions of psychic image and assign
them to objects here
mvac and rmvec which would then pass to
function operators
as the forward in vac and as the i joint
are in vec
the other two arguments here are just
giving the dimensions of input and
output
for this pilots operator so if we run
this we just generated our operator
and now what we've done is we've
effectively wrapped
the radon and iradon functions from
scikit image
into a pilot operator
now this allows us
to use the filtered free version of the
back projection before we showed you a
version
of the filtered back projection now we
can call iridone with no filter
this should represent what an adjoint is
supposed to be
provided that that was the adjoint to
the forward
radon as called by psychic image
so let's apply it and see what it looks
like
you can see here that we're now using
the fog as we defined right this is the
fault the this is the pylops operator
that is constructed
from scikit images functions and
uh we will make a forward projection and
then
we will make an adjoint projection here
so notice
that right here we're calling the
adjoint method of the pilot operator
which in turn points to the function
iradon without filter
if we do this we end up with this
picture that you see here so we take
the input which was the projected
version of the image using the pylops
operator which is calling
the radon function from scikit image and
then taking that as the input for the
adjunct reconstruction that you see on
the right hand side
give us the picture that we see here if
you scroll back for yourself and compare
it to the previous image you can see
that this looks blurry so clearly
the filter back projection is doing some
sort of sharpening
to the image so we end up with the
previous result that we saw
now the very important question if you
want to solve an inverse problem
is is this an adjoint remember that's a
requirement
for a pilot's operator so we can always
check whether a new pilot's operator
truly verifies the dot product tests
thereby saying
that this is or isn't a true adjoint
we can do that very easily by calling
the dot test function of pylops so this
is what you see here
and we'll see what happens
well as you can see iradon
from scikit image and radon do not form
a forward and adjoint pair what this
means for us
is that even though we wrapped it into a
pylops operator
we can't use these functions for solvers
that require
true adjoints so what can we do now
well next what we're going to do is
we're going to
leave a side or psychic image
functionality and just build one
from scratch using pylops how are we
going to do that
okay so the idea of building a radon
transform using pilots is actually very
simple
in concept the pseudo code for forward
projection operator is as stated here
for each angle theta we rotate the image
by that angle and once it's rotated we
just need to sum
or stack the values of that image over
one of the axes
now what would the adjoint looks like
the adjoint will take for each theta
the adjoint of the sum operation which
would be a spread
over a fixed axis and then rotate it
back
to the angle theta at which it was
rotated to begin with
that would be conceptually what the
forward and adjoint operators would be
now how can we do this in pilots
one way of doing this in pylops taking
advantage of an already existing pilot's
operator
is to recognize that a rotation
in practice numerically all it needs
is bilinear interpolation in fact it
doesn't have to be bilinear it can be
any interpolation but because bilinear
operations in polyps that's what we'll
use
now we represent here the bilinear
interpolation by the operator b for a
fixed angle theta
and after applying the bi-linear
interpolation
we will just uh devise a sum operator
here
and so for each angle theta what we have
to construct
is an operator that has stacks of
the bilinear interpolation that
represents the rotation plus the sum
at each angle theta starting at theta
zero at the top
then moving for each data sample down to
your last
theta sample as a cartoon
you can see here how bilinear
interpolation works
you can think of a rotated image as just
a interpolated version of your original
image in black
to the red values this is why we're
using by linear interpolation
notice that to ensure that the original
image
here indicated with the dashed red part
fits after you rotate the image one
trick that we used
all the way in the beginning of this
code was to pad the image with zeros to
extend its dimensions
so that when we rotate it it always fits
within
the interpolated grid okay so let's
illustrate this
with a single image here we're taking
uh our image and we're going to rotate
it
with a fixed angle so we start with the
image
we define the axes for the rotation via
linear interpolation so you can see the
input
and output axes defined here
then we define a rotation operator as a
simple change in coordinates you can see
here
that the r the rotation operator is a
well-known
trigonometric change in coordinates
we re-center it up to the axes
and then we plot so let's see what this
looks like
here you can see a cartoon of it you can
see the coordinates
uh overlaying on top of one another and
you can see the effect of the rotation
is effectively to select a new set of
coordinates that is interpolated
to the points that correspond to a
regular grid on a rotated axis
okay so now this means that we can build
a
pilot's operator off of it so what we do
is we take our rotation operator here
and we use it as a basis
for the bilinear interpolation this
allows us to simply define
a pilot's operator by calling the
bilinear interpolation from the signal
processing toolbox
within pylons therefore to rotate the
image itself
all we need to do is to now apply this
pylose operator to the image
and it should simply rotate the image by
applying bilinear interpolation
so let's see if that's what happens
here you go we now call the pilots
operator
rop and it applies by linear
interpolation
in order to effectively rotate the image
so you see the input image on the left
hand side
the rotated image on the right hand side
here you can also see
the effect of the dimension extension or
the zero padding
where you see that the original image
has larger dimensions
than the rotated image that's to ensure
that the image we want to rotate
fits within the output image
at all theta angles okay so this is
a rotation for one angle now let's make
an operator
that can apply this n times and
make the sum the projection for all the
angles
in order to do this we're going to
define a new operator
here it will take the original grid uh
create
a new grid off of it convert the angles
to radians
then we make this empty array that's
going to house
all of the appended arrays
all of the appended uh operators for
each one of the thetas which is what you
see here now we loop over thetas
uh create the r uh
change in coordinates that gives us the
data that we can interpolate
uh and then we can create a appended
pylops operator for each one of this
uh which contains the bilinear
interpolation that you see here
by calling the bilinear operator from
the signal processing toolbox of pylops
and then the sum operator applying next
to it
so this is the sb operator that we saw
in our definition above so we can now
evaluate this
this creates now our full radon
transform operator
for all angles of theta by
producing a bi-linear interpolation at
each theta that corresponds to the
rotation
followed by the sum over the fast memory
access
direction here which you can see here by
zero okay
okay so now we've created an operator
let's see how it works
so now we'll take our operator here we
make an object that actually contains
the operator
you can see there that it's already
showing us for the dimensions and
rotations that we want
what the dimensions of that operator is
then we can apply it as a forward pass
here
and then we can see what the projections
look like compared to the projections
that we created before
using uh the radon from
psychic image
so you see here on the left you see the
pilot's forward radon
in the middle you see the scikit image
radon and then you see their absolute
difference
notice that the difference is larger at
the edges
that's because in the shape logan
phantom uh
the edge the white edge that's around
the picture has the largest numbers and
therefore that's where you see the
largest differences
for the bi-linear interpolation errors
which is effectively
at the difference that you see in these
two projections
uh in any case this is a good forward
operator because you can see it comes
really close
to a third-party projection operator
thus giving us some confidence
that we've created a suitable projection
operator
the difference though between the
projection operator that we just created
and that of scikit image is that the one
we just created
has a well-defined adjoint because we
created it from
pileups operators that already had
well-defined adjoints
so we're using the advantage that when
you compound
pilots operators with well-defined
adjoints
the adjoint of that compound operator is
already well defined by itself
a consequence of this is that we can
directly use
our pileups operator now to estimate
inverses
to our problem so let's see
if we can use this for inversion to do
this
we're going to show you two examples of
inverse problems this is for the same
problem we have here
we have two options the first option the
one that you see on the top here is
called
l2 regularized inversion so in this case
we're going to try to solve a
least squares problem with a constraint
for smoothness so this term that you see
here is
weighing the weight of the laplacian
applied to the image so this is a
smoothing operator
against the least squares norm of
the misfit between the produced
projection and that that is observed
now the second option that we see here
is going to solve us technically an l1
problem
where what we're trying to do is
minimize the l1 norm
of the derivatives the first order
derivatives of the image
in two directions the x and y directions
while
using the least squares norm as a
constraint
okay this is called the tv regularized
inversion problem
and we'll see how we solve it here in a
minute let's start
with the top one the l2 regularized
inversion
okay so in order to do this we're going
to call
directly or least squares
inversion from the pileups library
in order to do this we need to provide
the regularization operator
and by that we can call the laplacian
that's already in pilops
and we'll pass or build pileups operator
that has the bilinear interpolation and
the sums
for the projection operator the
laplacian that we just create here and
then we'll call
our iterative regularized inversion
solver okay so we'll do that here
now this will take longer than a filter
break projection did as you can see here
because each iteration of this solver
needs to call one adjoint pass of the
operator
and the forward pass of the operator so
each one of these iterations already
costs
twice as much as a filter back
projection in principle
would cost now the way we set up our
inversion here
is it will stop when it reaches a
tolerance for the least squares norm
or when it reaches 20 iterations
now you can see here that it stopped at
20 iterations because it didn't quite
reach the tolerance level that we
predicted or asked for and then we'll
see what the result is
well on the left hand side you can see a
pretty good reconstruction of the image
now this reconstruction looks smooth and
it looks smooth
because we explicitly used a smoothness
constraint
by using the laplacian operator as the
regular riser
on the right hand side you can see that
the pattern of the errors
of the reconstruction looks different
than that of the filter back projection
that we saw before
this is expected of course because the
constraints we just used to solve the
problem
were not even present when we looked at
the filter back projection
now what happens if we use a different
solver
let's look at the second problem that we
looked at
and that was the problem of the tv total
variation regularization
now for the total variation we're going
to use what's called a split
bregman solver a split fragment solver
is designed to solve an
l1 optimization problem subject to the
least squares norm
in this case because we want the total
variation problem
the l one optimization problem
corresponds to maximizing
uh to minimizing the norm of the
one norm derivative first order
derivatives of the image
in both x and y directions so in order
to do that the first thing that we
do here in our code is create a pilot's
operator
that incorporates the directional
derivatives in the x in y direction
first order directional derivatives here
we can call the first derivative
operators
also from the pileups library
once we've built this then we can solve
the problem
by calling our solver from the
optimization libraries
of pylops now the sparsity promoting
library where l1 solvers are
and the split fragment solver which is
what you see here
as an input we're passing our operator
and we're now passing the operator that
we created
for the first order derivatives
then everything else is quite similar we
give it the data
and we specify either maximum number of
iterations
or a tolerance level
much like the least squares approach you
will see that this takes
longer much longer than a filtered back
projection
and that's because each iteration of the
split fragment solver
needs to call the forward and adjoint
operations
um in this case thus taking longer
now the split fragment solver also has
additional norms that it needs to
compute per iteration
which makes it more expensive than the
least square solution
so we have to sit here and wait until it
either reaches the minimum tolerance
that we want
or 20 iterations
so here's a third iteration
okay now that we've waited a bit until
we reached our total number of
iterations in this case you can see it
stopped at five iterations
uh we can see that what the result is
notice that the tv regularized result
gives us
a fairly good image reconstruction of
course it took a lot longer
because of the reasons i mentioned
before you can also see the error here
and the pattern of the error
again looking different and then
previous error patterns that we saw
if you'd like for yourself to quantify
and plot these errors relative to one
another with a specific
fixed scale feel free to do that
now we can visualize at last all our
reconstructions together
so for that we have our very last box
here we have all of our results starting
with the original image on the left hand
side and a little zoom of it
underneath on the second column then we
see the filter back projection
from scikit image and then from
the pilot operators that we created we
see the result of the least squares
inversion
and of the tv regularization tv
realization in this case is far superior
than the other two
because this original image is sharp and
so
using the sparsity promoting split
bregman solver
with a tv constraint gave us the best
results in this case
and of course both inversions look
slightly better than the filter back
projection because
of the ability of improve of imposing
constraints
and using well-established solvers
this is precisely what we want you to
learn and take away from pileups
and to give you an idea of how easy it
is to construct an operator
and use some of the state-of-the-art
solvers that we have here
i hope that you've enjoyed this exercise
we left
a few things for you to work on towards
the end of this notebook and we hope
you'll enjoy
and we're available for you for any
discussions or anything else
you would like to discuss thank you and
see you around